foreign
if you've ever been Enchanted by The
Poetry of Rumi listen to the Kawali
music of Nusrat Fateh Ali Khan or maybe
seen a powerful vicar session then you
have experienced an expression of what
is known as Sufism a word that is used
across the world and for different
context but which is often only known on
a surface level for most people
you may have heard that it is a part of
the religion of Islam that it is
spiritual in some way maybe even that it
is a very small Fringe sect of Islam
that is inherently peaceful and while
none of these
claims are necessarily false Sufism is
often greatly misunderstood and
misrepresented both within a non-muslim
and Muslim context in fact many may be
surprised to learn that Sufism has
played a significant role in the
majority expression of Islam throughout
history it was the mainstream and
remained sore in many parts of the world
still today that it has played a
powerful and major role not only for
individual practicing Muslims and their
spirituality but also played a major
role in politics and Empires Sufism is a
very Broad and complex topic and today
we're going to spend some time trying to
learn what this tradition is how it
developed over time and of course but
its main characteristics are so what
indeed is Sufism
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
Sufism is often described very briefly
as Islamic mysticism
there are some issues with this
simplifying definition since the two
terms cannot be directly equated and
that they often narrow each other down
too much but I often say that it can
still be a good starting point from
which we can then Nuance the discussion
further later on
Sufism is intimately connected to the
religion of Islam it appeared within
that religion although we can certainly
argue for outside influence impacting
its Origins too and the two have until
recently always been looked at in tandem
with each other
in fact for most of History it would
have been inconceivable to view Sufism
as its own category which would have
been compared to Islam it was Islam or
at the very least an aspect of that
religion neither should it be considered
a branch of Islam I see many people talk
about Sufi alongside Sunni and Shia as
branches of the religion but this is
very inaccurate
Sufism should rather be seen as a kind
of aspect or science within Islam
similar and alongside other aspects like
theology or thick Islamic law
I sometimes refer to Sufism as a
tendency within Islam a certain
practical and Theological tendency that
has certain characteristics but
certainly not as a branch
indeed sufis can be both Sunni or Shia
although historically most of them have
belonged to the Sunni group in
particular
and going back to that term mysticism
Sufism is a part of the religion that
certainly has aspects that we could turn
mystical in different ways in short
sufis have generally been Muslims that
have emphasized ethics to a large degree
as well as spiritual practices and ideas
about the imminence of God and the
ability to somehow achieve intimacy with
God in this life through rigorous
spiritual techniques that take you on
ascending stations toward that ultimate
goal of intimacy sometimes even referred
to as Union with God
the word Sufism is in a way a modern
academic term but it is based on a
self-description by the sufis themselves
the Arabic and internal term for the
tradition or spiritual science is which
means something like the path of
becoming a Sufi
so what is a Sufi then it's clear that
the term Sufi was being applied to
certain individuals very early on in the
Islamic civilization individuals that
would often adopt renunciant practices
or other ways of internalizing the
quranic message the Sunnah of the
Prophet Muhammad and to purify the soul
of egoism and vices
it is debated where this term Sufi
actually comes from and there are a few
theories the most widely accepted is
that it comes from the Arabic word suf
which means wool thus referring to the
kind of clothing that these renunciants
or quote unquote sufis would wear as a
sign of asceticism
another theory is that the word comes
from the asaba sufa the companions of
the bench this was a group of Companions
of the Prophet Muhammad that lived in
poverty and spent all of their life on
the bench or raised platform outside the
prophet's mosque in Medina dedicating
their lives to religious piety this
theory proposes that the word Sufi thus
comes from the sufa thus indicating that
the sufis are The Heirs of these
particular Companions of the Prophet
there is even a theory that the word
comes from the Greek term Sophia meaning
wisdom but this is the least accepted
among Scholars today
whatever the case these sufis are there
from the earliest periods of Islam
according to the sufis themselves Sufism
has been around since the time of the
Prophet Muhammad him thus being the
archetypal Sufi in a sense the person
that all sufis want to emulate this
connection also of course becomes clear
from the theory about the asaba sufa
historically it's hard to verify such
claims but what we can be sure about is
that the sufis as a distinct movement
appear in the historical record very
early on from the 8th Century or so
it's after this that people start being
referred to as sufis but like we said
sufis themselves will argue that even
though the name didn't exist the
phenomenon itself comes directly from
the prophet and even from before him an
attitude really well exemplified by the
Sufi figure Ali al-hudvery who writes in
the 11th century that quotes today
tasawolf is a name without a reality
whereas before it was a reality without
a name
some of these earliest sufis or perhaps
proto-surfies include figures like
visceral hafi or Bishop de Barefoot the
female rabi al-basri Abu Suleiman
adarani and
among others
it is in the later 9th century and early
10th that the movement really starts to
flower and to come into its own you
could say there were many parallel
mystical movements popping up at the
time not all of which can be called
Sufism without further nuancing you had
these so-called malamatiya in the east
in what is today Iran including famous
figures like Abu yazid al-bistami who is
famous for his controversial ecstatic
utterances like subhani which means
glory be to me
but also people all the way over in
Egypt like who developed very
significant ideas as well as Sahel
al-tustari and his Circle in Basra but
it was in the city of Baghdad that we
would see the development of a coherent
movement that self-identified as Sufi or
tasawof and which would become
paradigmatic and Incredibly influential
for the rest of History
they took inspiration from other Mystics
around the Islamic world that we have
just mentioned of course and they were
in contact with them but it is here in
Baghdad that many of these ideas are
systematized for the first time by
figures like al-muhasabi Abu said
Nuri and of course Junaid who is often
considered the leader of this Baghdad
School of Sufism it was these figures
not just the Baghdad school but all the
figures that I've just mentioned that
developed some of the key vocabulary
ideas and practices that would
characterize Sufism up until this very
day
[Music]
foreign
sufis are primarily concerned with
purifying the soul of traveling on the
path to intimacy with God they were
Muslims so they observed all the rituals
and practices of Islam this isn't some
parallel thing to the mainstream
religion sufis prayed five times a day
they fasted during Ramadan they
performed the pilgrimage to Mecca Etc
following the Sharia the Islamic law
with all that that entailed was a given
and these sufis were indeed particularly
strict about following all these outer
requirements of the Islamic religion
what made them unique in a way was that
on top of all these outer practices that
all Muslims performed they wanted to
further internalize the religion in a
deeper way
not only to follow the Motions of
external ritual but to have a more
direct relationship with God to where
the soul itself is also purified and
absolutely Pious and with a heavy focus
of course on ethics this is why they
often adopted renunciate and
semi-assetic Lifestyles and performed
separatory acts of worship
they not only fasted during Ramadan but
often some would fast all year round
eating very little
they would stay up most of the night in
separatory prayers they would give away
money and possessions and live lives of
poverty
and they also developed unique
techniques and practices with the aim of
aiding the soul on its journey toward
God
Sufism is in some ways an esoteric
tradition
by this I don't mean that it was hidden
since most of this stuff was very much
out in the open but inherent in the
tradition is a strong emphasis on the
relationship between a master and a
student when you enter on the Sufi path
you will take a master a Sheikh that
will guide you on the path through the
different spiritual stations macombs in
Arabic and its difficulties and dangers
the Sufi Master possesses the secrets of
the path which are only disclosed to
students and not necessarily to the
public
the sufis also like I said developed a
unique vocabulary of ideas and concepts
related to the spiritual path Concepts
like madifa which is often translated as
Gnostic knowledge or mystical knowledge
the sufis aren't necessarily concerned
with knowledge in the conventional sense
as in book knowledge or conceptual
knowledge at the very least this hasn't
been their primary focus
the kind of knowledge the Sufi seek is
another kind of knowledge knowledge that
isn't taught through words or books but
through experience and tasting
as you travel further on the Stations of
the path you develop a direct kind of
mystical knowledge of the Divine and of
reality and this is madifa and how is
this achieved well mainly through like
we said the purification of the soul and
particularly by fighting against your
nephs which is translated in this
context with things like ego or self
sometimes lower itself
this is the ego or self that has desires
and craves worldliness power money Etc
and leads to sin and Evil instead the
saw should be purified and clad with the
attributes of God especially in later
formulations conquering your nafs also
took on the form of literally stripping
away the very idea of an individual self
at all to become annihilated and will
return to this idea soon in Sufi
terminology there's often talk about the
so-called Jihad and nafs which means
they struggle against the ego or
struggle against the self as a key
impulse of the Sufi tradition and they
often connect this to a famous Hadith
when the prophet Muhammad was returning
with his followers from a battle against
the enemy and In This Moment he said we
are now returning from the the minor
Jihad or the Lesser Jihad which means
actual War conflict to the greater Jihad
which is rather the struggle struggle to
be a better person to to avoid sin and
and particularly in the Sufi context to
fight against or struggle against your
yourself or your ego
we also see the emphasis on love as an
important Concept in different ways a
development often associated with the
early female Sufi Rabia albasari and
later developed by others the Sufi path
is essentially one of Love of longing
for Union with the Divine beloved a
sense of pain from the separation from
God and a burning desire to travel on
the path back to God if you've ever read
Sufi poetry you will know how Central
the theme of love has been for this
tradition across history
but like I said this path also involves
certain unique and characteristic
practices
now we must remember that Sufism is
diverse and different sufis in different
places have adopted different practices
and ideas but probably the most
universal Sufi practice basically
employed across the board although its
form can differ slightly is what is
known as thicker
zikr means remembrance and refers to
remembrance of the Divine the Quran
repeatedly calls for believers to do
thicker to remember God constantly
the sufis took this command and
basically ritualized it you could say
they developed a practice of vikr where
one gathers in a group of other
Travelers under the guidance of the
Sheikh and basically chant the names of
God in vikr sufis will recite either the
names of God or perhaps more often the
Islamic proclamation of Faith
there is no God but God
this can be done silently but more often
it is done vocally in unison and is a
practice that can last for a very long
time
it can sometimes involve certain
movements of the head or body and at
times percussion instruments are used to
enhance the experience
the purpose of the good is right in the
name remembrance to remember God through
this chanting a practice that can often
become kind of trans inducing and help
the mind forget the individual self and
better be able to focus entirely on the
divine vicar was present already in
these earliest periods of Sufism and it
seems that the school in Baghdad around
figures like Junaid practiced it
another characteristic practice that
seemed to have developed in this early
period is something known as Sama which
literally means listening or sometimes
translated as audition in a way this is
kind of a more elaborate form of Dicker
but where the focus is on the act of
listening or hearing
this could mean simply listening to the
Quran being recited but it would often
involve melodic recitation of devotional
poetry and with music
had a very strong impact on the soul and
the sufis used it as a spiritual
technique of remembrance often
accompanied by movements of the body or
different kinds of dancing broadly
defined
scholar Jean during says quote Sama
which literally means audition denotes
in the Sufi tradition spiritual
listening and more particularly
listening to music with the aim of
reaching a state of grace or ecstasy or
more simply with the aim of meditating
of plunging into oneself or as the Sufi
say to nourish the soul
it thus operates in a mystical concert
of spiritual listening to music and
songs in a more or less ritualized form
we don't know the exact form that these
earliest summer sessions took but it is
a tradition that would later develop in
various different ways taking different
forms around the world all with the same
purpose of using music poetry and
dance to induce a State of Trance or
ecstasy this state of ecstasy is known
in Arabic as wajd and this practice of
sama involving listening to music and
sometimes dancing would be a powerful
technique for the souls traversing
toward God and for inducing mystical
experiences the famous Sufi writer al-ko
Shayari wrote quote they that is the
sufis say listening to music is a
delicious nourishment for the spirits of
divine gnostics
and he then tells this story quotes
sufis gathered around him
among them was a singer the sufi's asked
Donald's permission to have him that is
the singer perform something for them
he gave them his permission and the
singer began to recite then he sings
some lines of poetry on hearing this
though noon stood up and fell on his
face blood streaming from his forehead
onto the ground then one of the sufis
also stood up and displayed ecstatic
Behavior
there are many such similar stories
which indicate that these were very
powerful experiences indeed so Sama is
another very characteristic practice but
it should be pointed out that although
we see examples of sama in the earliest
periods of Sufism this is not a practice
that has been accepted across the board
it has been a somewhat controversial
practice even within Sufism not all
sufis or Sufi orders accepted some see
some actually see it as completely
illegitimate and as forbidden whereas
for other sufis and Sufi orders it has
been a very prominent and important
practice of Spiritual Development but it
seems clear to us that Sama was
practiced in the earliest periods of
Sufism both men and women would
participate although there was probably
some form of segregation although not a
complete segregation of course there is
even some evidence that women could lead
these Sama sessions which is really
interesting women seem to have been very
important in general for early Sufism as
both spiritual Masters and especially as
inspirational devoted Mystics and we saw
just one famous example of that earlier
with Rabia and all of this the fasting
night vigils General asceticism
all had the aim of helping the Sufi
Traverse that path of purifying his or
her soul
a path of ascending stations or macombs
Guided by a master that would culminate
in the highest station of intimacy and
Union with God an experience that has
been described in various different ways
by sufis in history but which is
generally referred to as fanaa meaning
Extinction or Annihilation at this point
the individual cell for ego of the
person becomes completely annihilated
and effaced in the reality of God and
the Mystic realizes that God is the only
reality
again this can be understood in
different ways but the most famous
expression of this experience of fanaa
probably comes from the 10th Century
Mystic al-halage associated with both
the circles of sahela tustari and Junaid
who in an intense moment of ecstasy
famously exclaimed anal haq which
literally means I am the truth or I am
the real
al-haq which means the truth or the real
is one of the names of God and the Quran
so it seemed that halaj was in some way
identify himself with God but what he
was actually doing according to the
sufis was to express that experience of
being annihilated completely to where
only God exists at that moment there is
no self to be identified with God so he
isn't saying that he is God but that
there is only God it's not a statement
of self-deification but of complete
self-denial halaj was a very
controversial figure among other things
for this statement but his fellow sufis
weren't upset that he was saying
something wrong per se but that was
disclosing secrets of the Sufi path to
people who were uninitiated and would
thus easily misunderstand which say
certainly did a lot of the time ecstatic
utterances like this are pretty common
in Sufism and are known in singular as
shat in Arabic another one of the most
famous examples of this comes from the
other early Mystic we mentioned earlier
al-bistami who exclaimed
or glory be to me which seems to point
to the same experience or reality as
halaj
these are some of the main
characteristics of Sufism as it
developed over the centuries and which
would remain key characteristics of the
tradition even up until this very day
although there are of course many other
aspects and and things that I haven't
had time to talk about the first wave of
systematization of tesawof and the
beginnings of its entry into a more
mainstream aspect of Islam comes with
the first Sufi manuals in the 10th and
11th centuries
textual works of Sufism that cover the
basics of its terms ideas and practices
as well as containing biographies of its
important foundational figures
these Works include the results
often known as the epistle on Sufism by
the already mentioned
or book of light flashes on Sufism by
abundasara saraj the kashval majub or
unveiling of the hidden by Ali
al-hojvidi and the
sustenance of hearts
these Works have served as key sources
for Sufi teachings and Concepts
throughout history and we still rely on
some other biographical accounts for our
knowledge of some of the earlier stupid
figures they also served as important
factors in The Wider acceptance of
Sufism in the Islamic world it is true
that the sufis and their practices were
considered suspect by some other Muslims
and these Sufi manuals served partly as
a way of proving or clarifying that Sufi
practices and ideas were in line with
the Islamic religion and its law and
this is precisely what we see a gradual
growth of Sufism and a wider acceptance
of its principles into mainstream
Islamic practice and theology especially
in the 11th to 12th centuries at which
point it basically becomes the
mainstream and remain the mainstream or
majority expression of Islam until
essentially the 19th century this
solidification of Sufism is often
associated with the figure
a very famous and influential scholar
Theologian and Mystic who in his
masterful work is the Revival of the
religious Sciences creates a masterful
grand synthesis of all aspects of
Islamic learning and practice where he
also incorporates tasawof and the Sufi
path as an essential part
gazali's Works became a paradigm for
orthodox Sunni Islam and thus was
incredibly influential in this regard
now he wasn't fully responsible for this
development himself as we saw this had
been a gradual development involving the
other Sufi writers I've mentioned but
there's no denying that ghazali and
related Figures were very important for
this solidification of Sufism as a
mainstream aspect of at least Sunni
Islam another key aspect that led in
this direction especially from the 12th
to 13th centuries was the development of
the Sufi orders
as we saw earlier Sufism was always
concerned with spiritual lineage with
the relationship between master and
student and these spiritual transmission
that was handed down in this kind of
line between master and student what
happens from the 12th century onwards is
that these lineages start to be
institutionalized in a more concrete way
a Sufi order known as a tariqa in Arabic
which literally means a path or a way
was a kind of organized spiritual
Community Based on a particular lineage
and the teachings and spiritual
techniques associated with a specific
Sufi personality that served as the
founder or main inspiration behind that
as an example one of the earliest Sufi
orders in history is the so-called
kaderia or kaderi order which remains
one of the largest and most widespread
in the world today
this tarika was formed around and takes
its name from the famous 12th century
baghdadi Sufi abdul-cladder al-jilani
another example is the more worldwide
famous Mev Levi order or maulavi order
which was formed based on the teachings
lineage and personality of the famous
Sufi poet jalala dinarumi and in this
case it's named after the common title
that he was called by mawlana or mevlana
which means our master
these orders have this idea of lineage
at the root and will always have a
particular chain of transmission or
silsila in Arabic unique to that order
any initiate in the order takes on a
master that was given spiritual
transmission by his master in the order
who was given it from his master and so
on
the silsila of a Sufi order always goes
to the founder of that order so in the
case of the claderia through
but also Beyond them and further back
all the way to the Prophet Muhammad
in other words all spiritual lineage in
Sufism claimed to go back to the prophet
himself and this is a very important
factor in their legitimacy which of
course also helped in The Wider
acceptance of Sufism in the Islamic
World inherent in this idea of silsila
and transmission is also the concept
that a spiritual master has a certain
spiritual Grace known as Baraka in
Arabic which is part of what is
transmitted in this line which stretches
back to the prophet
just being in the presence of a great
Sheikh can sort of like give you some
Baraka or spiritual Grace
even after a master has deceased some of
that Baraka remains which is the reason
why there is a strong tradition in
Sufism of visiting the graves or tombs
of Masters because it is thought that
these tombs often contain some of that
Baraka these are those places where it
is often beneficial to do things like
pray or meditate
these kinds of pilgrimages or visits to
to Masters tombs or living Masters which
is called ziara in Arabic which
literally means a visit these have been
emphasized on different levels by
different sufis some especially today
reject such tomb visits altogether While
others see it as a very Central practice
and this is indeed one point that sufis
are often criticized for by their
critics today
some Sufi orders have centers or
Regional complexes where they gather
together for things like zikr
will live in these complexes together
with the most dedicated disciples
these places which are called by
different names in different regions and
places names like darga
or zawia are often built in connection
with a grave site of a master
a prime example of this is the center of
the med Levy order which is in the city
of Konya in turkey and there's a large
complex that is in connection with the
tomb of Rumi himself who as we saw the
order is based on the Sufi orders can
differ on a number of fronts sometimes
pretty dramatically while all retaining
some of those core features that we have
outlined so far such as the practice of
Thicket for instance but other than this
each order will often have a particular
weird or prayer cycle given by Master to
student and also particular practices
and techniques to help the Mystic on the
path to God techniques that are often
associated with the orders founder and
again ultimately going back to the
prophet in some way
some of the most prominent and famous
Sufi orders in the world include the
already mentioned claderia which can be
found all over the world there is also
the shadelier associated with Abu Hassan
as shadowy and is common especially in
North Africa
The nakshbandiya prominent in Central
Asia the chishtiya primarily associated
with the Indian subcontinent the Mev
levia associated with Rumi and his
lineage the tijaniya very popular in
West Africa and of course many many more
most of these orders are primarily
associated with Sunni Islam but there
are cases of overlap and sometimes even
more overt she orders such as the
nematullahi order for instance
add to this the fact that most Sufi
orders have sub-branches and even
sub-branches within sub-branches that
will have particular characteristics of
their own and you'll quickly realize
that this is a very Broad and complex
topic it really is a vast world when it
comes to Sufism but regardless these
Sufi orders have played a major role in
in Islamic history and it's been through
these orders and these brotherhoods that
most people have associated with and
practice Sufism in connection to these
different orders at least since the 12th
century up until today with this wider
spread of Sufism and its
institutionalization into these orders
and wider Acceptance in mainstream Islam
so to say we also see more expressions
of Sufism in particular in different
forms indeed Sufism today is perhaps
most famous around the world for its
different artistic expressions like a
music poetry and literature for example
they're developed over the century
especially through the importance of the
Sufi ritual of sama various different
kinds of musical styles and practices
that will be colored by local customs
and styles and thus created a vast world
of Sufi music that still exists today
I'm in a full episode exploring Sufi
music in particular which you should
definitely check out if you're
interested
also at around the same time we start to
see more poets combining things like the
witch tradition of love poetry with Sufi
ideas to create literary masterpieces
expressing the spiritual path and its
mystical experiences
many of these Sufi poets have become
famous worldwide for their ability to
both encapsulate Islamic ideals and deep
mystical fervor in a way that is
universally accessible and profound
in the Persian speaking world you have
giants like jalaladin Rumi whose
Masterpiece the masnavi has sometimes
been called the Quran in Persian
there is also faridudin at Todd and his
conference of the birds which remains
one of the great works of literature and
history and half his and his beautiful
love poetry in the Arabic world you have
Sufi poets like IBN faded Urban Arabi
the ecstatic and controversial study and
female figures like the early Mystic
Arabia albasari and later Aisha
al-bawania
in the turkish-speaking realm you of
course have figures like yunus emre
Ahmed yesvi and many more these are just
a few of the most famous examples and
indeed only covers the Middle Ages there
are many more famous Sufi poets in all
kinds of languages from this time and
all the way until today in these poems
you will find the ideas and teachings of
Sufism in Islam expressed through
various kinds of metaphors and poetic
language
one of the most common themes is of
course love the relationship between the
lover and beloved and they're wanting to
unite with each other as a metaphor for
the mystical Quest
or the theme of wine and intoxication
representing that Divine love or direct
experience of the Divine and the
intoxication that results from it one of
the most famous Sufi poems is called the
song of the read and it's in fact only
the opening section of a much larger
poem called the masnavi by the
world-renowned Persian Sufi poetin Rumi
here Rumi uses the metaphor of the nay
or the read flutes and how its beautiful
music is a cry of longing to be returned
to its home in the read bed as a
reflection of the human longing to
return to Unity in God
caught listen to this read as it is
grieving it tells the story of our
separations
since I was severed from the bed of
reeds in My Cry men and women have
lamented
I need the breast that's torn to shreds
by parting to give expression to the
pain of Heartache
whoever finds himself left far from home
looks forward to the day of his reunion
or in the beautiful poetry of the 16th
century Sufi Aisha al-bawaniya who
exclaims in one of her poem songs quote
your beauty bound me tight and when
appear the light gone was my shadow my
shadow
and it stripped me and nothing remained
of me as it annihilated me as was right
I left myself and went away my veil was
gone and nearness appeared my union my
union
for yet astonished then revived me and
he gave me new life in Beauty
furthermore in the Poetry of the Arabic
Sufi poet IBN faded we find similar
expressions of the ecstatic moments of
Union with the ego is dissolved and the
boundary between lover and beloved melts
away caught
I sought her from myself she was there
all along how strange that I had
concealed her from me
calling to myself from me to guide me by
my voice to that part of me lost in my
search
me begging me to raise the screen by
lifting up the veil for I was my only
means to me
when you read this kind of poetry or
Sufi literature in general you might be
struck by the way in which it describes
God and the relationship between God and
the human being or the world in general
it seems a far cry from the
stereotypical image of Islam and its
utterly Transcendent God
Sufism seems to have a metaphysics of
its own a theology distinct from
mainstream Islam is this true what is
the world view of the sufis
well many might be surprised to learn
that in general it's not very different
at all from other Muslims at least not
in its foundations
like we said Sufism for most of History
was mainstream Islam Sufism comes from
Islam and is based on the teachings of
the Quran and the Sunnah the Prophet
Muhammad
most sufis in history would have adhered
to one of the mainstream Creeds of
theology in Sunni or Shia Islam what is
known as akhida like the the ashadi
school or the maturity School major Sufi
figures like kazali for example were
great Defenders of the ashadi School of
Theology in particular
so this is important to remember that
Sufism and Sufi theology is Islamic
theology at least in its foundations
now with that said it's also true that
sufi's
compared to non-sufi Muslims have
emphasized certain aspects of theology
or of the Divine more so than the
non-sufi Muslims and have sometimes at
least within what they see as the the
bounds of Orthodox Islamic theology
established ideas that are a bit more
unique to Sufism in particular
perhaps above all this involves an
emphasis on the imminence of God
Islam teaches that God is utterly
Transcendent unlike anything in the
created world
basically all sufis would agree with
this but at the same time Islam also
teaches that God is present and somehow
imminent
the Quran says that quotes whichever way
you turn there is the face of God or
quotes we or God are closer to them than
their jugular vein
and these are the kinds of verses that
sufis will often emphasize to point to
the great imminence of God
God can be experienced somehow in this
life not just in the afterlife and he's
present here and now
we've seen that a common theme for sufis
is the wish to annihilate their self or
ego to become United with God quote
unquote
or rather to become effaced in the
reality and attributes of God if you
want to be more technical about it and
this idea of imminence and presence as
well as the balance between both a
Transcendent and imminent God occupied
many Sufi thinkers in history
generally they will fall on a spectrum
of just how much this imminence and
presence is emphasized
the idea of annihilation and its
consequences often have a kind of
built-in monism a lot of the time if
you'll allow me to use a somewhat
problematic term when the Mystic
annihilates himself he realizes that God
was the only reality to begin with there
was no individual self and now they see
reality for what it is God
but how far can one draw these ideas
this kind of modism where God is the
only reality is present in a lot of
Sufism sometimes only slightly hinted at
but other times a very overt and clear
but as we said there's a kind of
spectrum of intensity
from relatively moderate expressions and
fingers like ankhazali to the more
radical ideas of someone like mohedin
even Arabi
he is one of the most if not the most
influential Sufi metaphysicians who
argues that God is being itself and that
being is one
his Doctrine would later come to be
referred to as
or the unity or Oneness of being and has
been incredibly influential
the world and its multiplicity is simply
the reflections or manifestations of
God's infinite attributes and its being
which ultimately doesn't belong to it is
identical to God who is the one being
one of God's names is meaning the truth
or the real and IBN Arabi takes this
quite literally God is the real so that
when we say the proclamation of Faith
there is no God but God we can also
translate that to there is no reality
but the real
in other words in some sense God is all
that there is and this kind of idea is
indeed quite prominent in Sufi thinking
while it isn't really accepted to the
same degree in non-sufi Islam
we have to keep in mind though that
Sufism like we said has been the
mainstream of Islam from Muslim history
and so we shouldn't draw two clear
distinctions like that and while someone
like IBN Arabia has been very
influential popular and significant for
Sufism and especially for Sufi
metaphysics not all sufis or even
perhaps the majority of sufis adhere to
his more radical ideas of Oneness
or at the very least many will be
careful about such expressions
like I said there is a kind of spectrum
of how much these ideas are emphasized
we even have thinkers that are arguably
more radical and monistic than IBN Arabi
such as IBN
and their concept of
absolute Oneness but at the same time
also sufis on the other side but are
very careful to talk about God in such a
way
so that's the general idea sufis are
Muslims and so follow the basic
theological tenets of Islamic theology
for the most part but have also
emphasized certain aspects and certain
Concepts more than non-sufi Muslims such
as the imminence of God and the ability
to somehow experience God in this life
sometimes even going as far as saying
things like that that God is is the
ultimate God is the only reality and
that the world of Multiplicity is some
kind of Illusion or reflection surface
level reflection and these ideas can be
found all over Sufi poetry and art as we
can see
quote he is all of being and he is the
one in whose being my being resides
there's a balance that is often upheld
between the imminence and
all-encompassing reality on the one hand
and his Transcendence and utter
difference from all things on the other
and that connects to another teaching or
aspect of the Sufi world view which we
mentioned briefly earlier
to the sufis this knowledge of God or
true experience of God cannot be reached
through intellect or through conceptual
knowledge
this is what distinguishes them from the
philosophers for instance or the
rational theologians although of course
individuals can sometimes be both at the
same time
that is that the sufis are primarily
interested in another kind of knowledge
in the direct intuitive mystical
experience of the truth reached by
mystical practice and illumination the
madifa that we talked about earlier
rather than any kind of knowledge that
can be reached through thinking or
rational inquiry
philosophical thinking only gives us
knowledge of Multiplicity and the
concepts of this world which are
ultimately useless in the bigger picture
instead it is Mystical knowledge Valk
literally means tasting that is
emphasized IBN Arabi talks about looking
at the world through two eyes the eyes
of rational or conceptual thinking which
leads to seeing God as Transcendent and
different tansia and the eye of mystical
Insight on the other hand which leads to
seeing God as imminent and similar
tashbir the Oneness of it all
for this reason when we read many Sufi
works such as IBN arabis fusos
we find that they aren't written like
philosophical Works they're not
arguments based on rational thinking but
laid down knowledge as reached through
cash unveiling of the truth directly to
the Mystic
this is also by poetry served as such a
great tool to express these truths
rather than technical prose for instance
and with these more philosophical
tendencies in soupy thinking we also see
a further development of the idea and
role of the Sheikh or illuminated master
the person who has annihilated his ego
that has reached madifa through
unveiling of the truth and tasted it for
himself becomes a spiritually exalted
human being
not only can he or she of course teach
others on the path as a Sheikh or Sheikh
but they even have a can of cosmic role
to play
the highest Masters become what is
called aolia or Wali in singular which
is often translated as Saints but
actually means something like friend of
God
they have a kind of proximity to God
through having reached the states of
fanaa and Baka being annihilated and
then returning to the world of
Multiplicity and now they hold Spiritual
Authority and barakah the grace that we
talked about earlier and there was even
a kind of ranking among the awliyah with
the highest of them being the kutub or
the spiritual pole of a certain age
there is always such a poll in the world
and when he or she passes away another
one replaces them
this authority of the awliyah and the
pole of course ultimately stem from the
prophets like Muhammad to whom they are
kind of Representatives or heirs they
never reach the level of a prophet
themselves of course since the line of
Prophecy ended with Muhammad but they
still are the kind of highest living
Spiritual Authority in the world
under the influence of thinker slack
even Arabi they're even developed
further metaphysical ideas about the
so-called insan al-kamal or the perfect
man or maybe the complete human being
in these ideas the insanal camel becomes
a kind of metaphysical logos principle
that can be reflected or manifested in
this world
the most complete and absolute
manifestation of this perfect man
principle is of course the prophet
Muhammad himself but the awliya and
accomplished Masters also take on this
role as a reflection of the insane and
camel they have reached the end of the
spiritual journey and fully realized the
ultimate human potential of embodying
the attributes of God
these are of course very complex
metaphysical ideas and I do dive deeper
into them in some of my earlier more
in-depth videos but needless to say the
spiritual illuminated Master the the the
Wali is a very Central Concept in Sufism
and in the surface tradition not just of
course as a spiritual teacher to new
students but also for his larger role in
both the world and in the larger Cosmos
so these are some of the basics of Sufi
teachings as they developed in their
more systematized forms in the Middle
Ages
but we should not fall into the Trap of
of talking about superism and think
about superism in a sense that it hasn't
developed further since the Middle Ages
a lot of people even Scholars often make
this mistake of talking about the Middle
Ages and not
later centuries and today and how things
have developed Sufism of course has
continued to develop and change over
these centuries even though certain key
characteristics that we have talked
about do remain key principles and
aspects but I focus so much on this
period here because it is so formative
in many ways it is in this period that
many Sufi ideas are systematized and
formalized in a concrete way for the
first time and that Sufism is also
institutionalized through the Sufi
orders in a way that would continue to
be very
influential throughout history like we
said from this period from the Middle
Ages especially like 11th 12th 13th
century Sufism basically becomes
mainstream Islam it is part of the
mainstream majority expression of Islam
right up until the modern age in the
19th
20th century and sometimes in in some
parts of the world today it still holds
this kind of position a good example is
West Africa in places like Senegal and
The Gambia where over 90 percent of the
population are Muslims and a further 90
of those Muslims are connected to Sufi
brotherhoods and are sufis sort of say
this kind of reflects the way that
Sufism worked historically
um
but maybe not so much in many other
parts of the Islamic world today for
reasons that we will get to a little bit
later sufis in history served in
government positions Emperors and
Sultans were greatly influenced by Sufi
teachings and were even sometimes sufis
themselves
we just have to look at the Mughal
Empire and figures like Akbar or
darashoko to see examples of this or the
fact that nakshbandi sufis held
considerable political power in Central
Asia during the inchanic period that the
Iranian safavid empire grew out of a
Sufi order and many other such factors
or even the strong connection between
Sufism and the ottoman Sultans and the
ottoman State all of this shows us that
the common idea of sufisa as purely
ascetic unpolitical peaceful Muslims
aren't always true to reality
to be sure many sufis were completely
uninterested in politics just look at
Ashu study for instance or the chishti
Sufi order in India who often refuse any
association with worldly power but at
the same time many others have been
deeply involved with political Affairs
across history and while Sufi is often
taught compassion rather than were often
quote unquote peaceful they also
participated in wars and supported
policies that we would consider
oppressive what I'm saying is that the
topic isn't black and white but
considerably more nuanced there isn't
just one kind of Sufi peaceful or not
peaceful politically involved or
renunciate but a diverse array of
different kinds of approaches
sufis are often very strict about
following Islamic law for instance
although there is a point to be made
that many sufis were less quote-unquote
formalistic in terms of the Sharia that
religious practice wasn't all about the
outward formalities of the law but
rather the inner state of the heart
one's intentions and personal
relationship with God certainly we find
this kind of attitude and people like
Rumi for instance or in IBN Arabi who
often complains that people in his day
have made Islam shallow only practicing
the outward forums of the religion while
forgetting the inner deeper meanings but
they should not be confused with
completely rejecting the law or being
less strict about the law being followed
this is simply not the case at least
most of the time although there have
been certain minority anti-normal groups
such as the kalandaria the latter of
whom often consciously did things that
were seen as transgressionary from
urinating in public to shaving off their
hair beard and eyebrows all as a
spiritual practice to fight the ego by
consciously attracting the spite of
other people
sufis are complex in other words and we
should be careful to place any such
black and white labels on them there's
nothing wrong with calling sufi's
peaceful since again many of them
certainly emphasize such ideals and
especially in today's climate will be
can't paint with two broad Strokes when
doing so
and arguably today the situation is even
more complicated than it has been
historically
although to subwoof isn't as prominent
throughout the Islamic world as it was
earlier it still is a significant
presence across the world
like I said in places like Senegal where
over 90 of the population are Muslim an
additional 90 of those Muslims belong to
a super Brotherhood
if you travel to Morocco or India you
can see an experience not only a living
Sufi tradition but the various ways that
Sufism has influenced the culture and
religious practice of the people
in other words Sufism is alive and well
even today and in various different ways
but it is also true that it has become
significantly less prominent in the
Islamic World from an overarching
perspective and there are different
reasons for this I've spent a full
episode earlier talking about the
relationship between Islam and Sufism in
the modern world and how Sufism has been
increasingly seen as separate from the
larger religion but in short terms It's
a combination of colonialism and the
connected rise of modernist reform
movements within Islam that looked at
Sufism as Superstition basically
to the modernist Muslims of the 19th and
20th Century Sufism was an idol ideology
based on Old superstitious tradition
which had polluted the rational
quote-unquote true religion of Islam
which they sought to reconstruct
some of these modernist traditions of
the more radical swords such as these
so-called salafis and wahhabis similarly
see Sufism as reprehensible Innovation
accusing sufis of things like grave
worshiping
for different reasons among other things
Western interventions and colonialism
these modernist movements within Islam
became very popular over the course of
the 20th century and has thus influenced
the general situation to a major degree
similarly orientalist Scholars and
Europeans that got their hands on Sufi
literature had a hard time reconciling
their preconceived notions about Islam
with the beautiful and sophisticated
ideas of Sufism so increasingly they
pushed the idea that they must somehow
be two different things that Sufism and
mysticism survived in spite of Islam
rather than as a result of it
in other words this idea of
quote-unquote Sufism as a category that
can be distinguished from Islam somehow
or even seen as two fundamentally
different things became more pronounced
through these developments from
different fronts both from within the
Islamic world and from the outside
and while Sufism has seen a kind of
resurgence in some regions today the
general situation Still Remains sufis
are comparably marginal in some major
parts of the Islamic world and even face
oppression in some places
in all this the sufis in the Islamic
world today often emphasize their role
as representing a true traditional Islam
that is open and tolerant and peaceful
in opposition to the more modernist and
often fundamentalist radical movements
within Islam like salafism and wahhabism
this is a very in fact a very important
aspect of many sufi's self-understanding
today sort of identifying themselves in
opposition to these other groups at the
same time with increased globalization
Sufism has also made its way into the
into the West to a much larger degree
today not only through of course
immigrants coming from the Middle East
and the Islamic world and bringing their
native tradition with them but also
through other means Sufism entering
Europe and America as a kind of
Universalist spirituality this idea
becomes very prominent in the 20th
century a Sufism that is
not necessarily connected to Islam but
seen as part of this larger perennial
wisdom or Universal spirituality an idea
that was very much influenced and
spearheaded by by movements like the
theosophical society writers like Idris
Shaw
to some degree the perennialist movement
and of course also the general interest
in eastern spirituality in the sort of
60s and 70s all these developments also
led to a new kind of Sufism in a way
appearing in the Western World a key
figure in this development is the
chishdi Sufi teacher in nayat Khan who
is often said to have been the first
figure to bring Sufism to the west and
increasingly he presented it in a more
Universalist form you didn't have to be
Muslim to be Sufi in other words and
this idea of Sufism has continued to be
very popular to this day
so we see various kinds of Sufism around
the world currently it's certainly a
global phenomenon but sufis can look
rather different depending on the
context there are those that are still
deeply connected to the traditional
forms of tasaworth as simply the way
that Islam is practiced organized in the
established Sufi orders and their
spiritual lineages
but there are also many Sufi groups and
individuals that emphasize Universalist
interpretations where adherence to Islam
isn't necessarily a requirement and
various approaches in between on a kind
of spectrum in other words while it is
quite easy to say that Sufism is
fundamentally a part of the religion of
Islam when looking at its history that
statement isn't as obviously true in all
cases today at least without further
nuancing
Sufism continues to play a major role in
politics in places like Senegal
individual sufis around the world
continue to perform the characteristic
practices like Dicker and Sama as part
of their spiritual and religious life
and its writings and arts serve as
subject of study admiration and
Fascination for all kinds of people both
Muslims and non-muslims
indeed as we've said on a global level
Sufism is probably most famous for its
aesthetic and artistic Expressions the
poems of Rumi although often
questionably translated are incredibly
popular as are those of hafez or atar
furthermore these strong musical
tradition of Sufism has also become
something a phenomenon
not only does Sama continue to serve as
a central practice for many sufis but
its various Expressions have become
famous as an art form too the Kawali
music of people like the Pakistani
singer Nusrat Fateh Khan is famous all
around the globe and the wording
dervishes of the immobility order in
Turkey serves as popular tourist
entertainment
at the same time it is a tradition that
is often misunderstood or misrepresented
many of the translations of Rumi for
instance often erase the Islamic
contents of his poetry and we have
already discussed some of the ways in
which Sufism and its relationship with
Islam has been portrayed in the last
century or so hopefully this humble
episode has dispelled some of those
misconceptions and giving you a broader
and more nuanced overview of this very
fascinating and significant tradition
it's history and development and some of
its most characteristic ideas and
expressions like I said there's already
plenty of content on this channel
covering Sufism and Diving deeper into a
lot of those topics that I've only
brushed over very briefly in this
episode so if you're interested in
learning more and Diving deeper and
going down the rabbit hole so to say
check out some of those other episodes
on this channel and you can of course
look forward to more Sufi content in the
future I have no plans of stopping at
this point it's a topic that keeps
coming back and I know a lot of you guys
in the audience also get really enjoy
this content so look forward to a lot of
that
as always of course I would like to
extend a special thank you to all of my
patrons who support this channel
monetarily I would not be able to do any
of this without your support it really
means the world to me it really helps
this channel function it really helps me
produce this free educational content
that I am so passionate about and I know
that a lot of you are passionate about
also out there so it really it means the
world to me it is my honor to be able to
to do this so thank you all so so much
thank you also of course for simply
watching uh liking and subscribing to
the channel and for all the wonderfully
interesting and fascinating discussions
that I had in the comments I have to say
I'm really proud of the community that
we've built here
considering the topic that is discussed
on the channel religion you'd think that
the discussions in the comment sections
would be absolutely Dreadful but I'm
continuously surprised by how respectful
and nice and and just it's good people
all of you are the discussions and the
comments are often really interesting
and there is always a not always but you
usually a positive tone in the comments
so I you you guys should be really proud
of that and I I am proud of that as well
so thank you so much uh thank you again
for watching and I will see you next
time
[Music]
thank you